- Welcome everyone.
This session is for data scientists
and AI developers that are
looking to customize models
and deploy at scale to build high quality
and cost effective agentic applications.
Let's get started.
We are seeing two big trends
in the market, in the industry.
First, we are seeing rapid
adoption of agentic AI
in enterprise software apps.
This adoption is expected
to grow to 33% by 2028,
from 1% in 2024 to 33% by 2028.
That's a 33x increase in just four years.
To build these agentic applications,
you need models that are high quality,
cost effective and fast,
and customers are increasingly
relying on open weight models
to build out these applications.
Despite huge opportunity
and clear line of sight on how
to build these applications,
we continue to see that
majority of applications
never reach production.
Let's take a look at what
are the key challenges
that customer face which
leads to these failures.
First, customers lack standardized tools
to customize models with
different techniques.
So they end up spending time
building out these workflows,
standardized tools,
which delays the time
to customize the models.
Once the models are customized,
you need an inference
stack to host these models
with the right price performance ratio.
It takes a lot of effort
to find the right instance,
right container configuration,
constantly adapt new inference
optimization techniques
that are coming in
to ensure that your inference stack
is meeting the latest requirements,
which is complex and
requires ton of effort,
which further delays the
timelines for these products.
After the model is deployed,
customers need tools to track
the behavior of these
models and the agents.
Often the observability is fragmented
across two different tools,
which makes root causing
and debugging of the behavior much harder,
further delaying any progress.
And then once you
identify all these issues,
now it's time to take
your model customization
workflow into production.
And often the experimentation
work is done with glue code,
which doesn't scale well
when you try to deploy that to production.
So often these pipelines
need to be rebuilt,
and this disconnect
leads to further delays.
And lastly, to deploy these
models at an enterprise scale,
you need the right governance practices.
You need capabilities to track, audit
and version your models'
generative AI assets
so that you can ensure as
they move from dev to staging
to production environments,
you can keep right track
and ensure the meet compliance
and governance requirements
before they can be
deployed to the customers.
I'm Amit Modi,
senior manager for SageMaker
Model Operations and Inference.
And I have with me Dan,
who's our worldwide specialist for GenAI,
and Ying who leads the
co-creator of SGLang.
In this session we'll do a quick overview
of all these maker capabilities
that can help you address
some of these challenges.
Then Dan will do a demo
that will bring all these
capabilities to life.
And then Ying will talk about
some of the key highlights
for SGLang that helps you host
cost optimized inference at scale.
So let's dive in.
SageMaker offers capabilities to train
and fine tune these models.
SageMaker offers the
broadest selection of models,
all popular open source models,
as well as Amazon Nova models
that you can use to get started.
They meet all the enterprise requirements.
We've already gone through
the security scanning
and so on, so you can quickly get started.
You can choose from the
broadest range of recipes
to fine tune your model
and customize them.
We'll take a bit of,
little bit of a deeper
dive into these recipes
in coming slides.
And you can also choose
from the right training infrastructure
to train these models,
whether you want ephemeral compute
with fully managed training jobs
or you can have persistent
clusters to run large scale jobs
with SageMaker HyperPod.
SageMaker has built in resiliency
into these infrastructure,
which helps you train your models faster.
Let's take a look at
some of the key capabilities of training.
So the first key capability
that SageMaker offers
is when you got these
training jobs in HyperPod,
it constantly checkpoints these jobs.
So in case there is a node
failure on the cluster,
the cluster self heals by
replacing with a good node
and then resumes the training
job from the last checkpoint.
So your work is never lost
and it also accelerates the training
because there are multiple node failures
that happen during the day.
The self-healing cluster makes,
it takes away the burden from
you to identify those nodes,
replace them, resume the job
from the last checkpoint.
All of this is taken care for
you as a managed capability.
Another key capability is
these fine tuning recipes.
So SageMaker offers fine tuning recipes
to customize your model
for most commonly used popular models
and for most common techniques.
You can get started by
putting your data training
and validation data into
the right directories.
Identify the right recipe
for you, for your use case
and then kick off the recipe on either
on the fully managed training jobs
or on the HyperPod clusters,
depending on your computer requirements.
Next, let's take a look
at SageMaker AI inference.
We talked about the key
challenge with inference was
to host cost-effective inference.
You need capabilities
so that you can deploy
your models faster quickly.
SageMaker AI inference offers
capabilities that allow you
to deploy open source
or fine tune models with a couple of steps
onto a managed instance,
either through UI or through SDK.
You can choose to host
any model on any framework
on any different type of infrastructure
to make sure you're getting
the best performance.
SageMaker out of the box
offers high throughput
and low latency for your endpoints,
and we'll take a little bit of deeper dive
into some of these features.
With SageMaker, you can
deploy multiple models
onto the same endpoint.
This ensures that you can
scale the one endpoint
to all your use cases
to drive the maximum
utilization out of GPUs.
The intelligent routing
built into the endpoint
redirects the request to the right model
and ensures there is
no performance penalty.
You can scale up to hundreds
of models in the same endpoint
depending on the memory requirements.
SageMaker also emits metrics
for each of these models.
So you can configure autoscaling policies
for each model separately.
This allows your SageMaker
inference endpoint
to autoscale as the traffic grows.
In this use case, you can see
the foundation model three has
high traffic and it can autoscale only
for the foundation model three
and make sure it meets the requirements.
Next, we recently launched a
capability that also allows you
to get better throughput out
of these, out of these models.
the expectation for
customer for inference is
that they need fast
inference and fast response.
In reality, these LLMs
generate one token at a time,
which makes it really hard to
meet the customer expectation.
We launched speculative decoding recently.
Speculative wording works this way.
So you have a foundation model
and you have a draft model.
The draft model is a smaller
model that does predictions
for the prompt
and the foundation model
validates this prediction
with calculating some probabilities.
It accepts some of the
tokens, it rejects REST.
This is a simplistic
view of how this works.
In reality, you can have draft model
actually produce out multiple variations
that certain foundation
models can choose from.
So let's take a quick look at an example.
In this case, the foundation model
and the draft model get the prompt.
The draft model produces
the next set of tokens.
Foundation model decides which one,
what is the probability for each token
and accepts some of these tokens.
And this is how speculative code occurs.
This leads to latency reduction
and up to 2.5x higher
throughput for your model
without compromising on the accuracy.
And all these capabilities
work out of the box.
So the way it works is you
bring your own data set,
which maps to your traffic patterns
and use that data set to
fine tune the draft model
so the draft model can
do better predictions.
You run SageMaker,
kicks off an asynchronous training job
to fine tune your draft model.
After the draft model is fine tuned,
you can look at the evaluation metrics,
choose to deploy that on
the same SageMaker endpoint
without provisioning a new instance,
and then the speculative
recording gets started.
Out of the box, SageMaker
offers managed containers
to host more popular
frameworks like vLLM or SGLang.
SageMaker offers open source containers
with deep learning containers,
which offer these two flavors
of most common frameworks
or using a proprietary LMI container
that also offers TensorRT LLM.
Today we also announced the launch
of serverless MLflow on SageMaker.
With serverless MLflow, it's
fully managed experience
so you don't need to worry about
managing any infrastructure
and it's all serverless
so it scales up and down
based on your requirements
for when you're running a
large scale training job
or you are sending out the agent traffic.
We'll talk about those use cases in a bit.
You can log your experiments,
run evaluation results
or agent traces all in one place.
And serverless MLflow is free.
It does not have any additional charges.
So here is a screenshot of
how the experiment
tracking works with MLflow.
You can see within an
experiment all the runs,
which is basically each training run,
you can compare and
contrast the training run
to identify the best candidate model
that you want to take to production.
So you have all the
observability from the time
of model customization.
If you're using AgentCore
for deploying your agents
and SageMaker AI for
customizing the models,
AgentCore already emits all the traces
into AgentCore observability dashboards
and you can also send them to MLflow
because they meet the OTel requirements
or the open telemetry specifications.
SageMaker also offers partner
AI apps as 1P capabilities,
which are third party apps
that can also help you monitor agents
as well as the model performance.
So now let's take a
look at how this works.
You can now see on the left side
there's a complete trace tree
starting with the InvokeAgent at the top,
drilling down through the
workflow build process,
capturing each step of
the LangChain operations
and even showing the tool calls,
and you can see multiple
assistant interactions too.
This hierarchical view gives
you the complete visibility
into every step of the agent,
including the conditional
branches and iterations,
which makes it easy to
root cause any issues
within the agents.
And you can go down to
the model customization,
see which model was used,
what dataset was used,
which makes debugging much more easier.
Now that you have your
experimental workflows figured out,
you have all your
observability in one place.
You need capabilities to productionize
all these experimental workflows
into scalable and repeatable workflows.
SageMaker AI offers pipelines.
You can simply convert your
existing experimental code
into pipeline steps by annotating,
whether add the rate
step annotator in code
or drag, drop all of these steps into a UI
to create a end-to-end pipeline.
SageMaker also offers
built-in steps for training,
evaluation and deployment that
eliminates the need for you
to write any redundant wrapper code
for spinning up the training
jobs and any infrastructure,
and Pipelines is all
serverless orchestration,
so you don't need to
manage any infrastructure.
We emit all the telemetry to CloudWatch
where you can observe the
behavior of each pipeline step.
SageMaker Pipelines also
have caching built in it.
So if a pipeline fails and
you re-trigger the pipeline,
it'll skip the steps
that were already successfully executed.
Lastly, for governance we
talked about how you need
to keep track of
and manage each version of
the generative AI assets.
So SageMaker offers Model Registry,
which is the single source of truth
for all your model versions.
SageMaker AI Model
Registry is a central hub
to manage the entire lifecycle
of the machine learning models.
We'll take a look into some
of those key capabilities
in a moment.
You can track all the
metadata corresponding
to the training jobs, evaluation runs
and so on into SageMaker Model Registry.
So here with SageMaker Model Registry,
you can set up cross account
access that allows you
to track all the models
in all your environments
in one place,
so you can track not only the environment
that you're working in
but also your staging
and the production environments.
Model Registry also enables
you to capture all the details
of the training job so you
can have end-to-end lineage of
what the model went through,
which makes it much more easier
to debug in case you run into any issues.
Next, I will hand it over
to Dan who will walk us
through the demo to bring all
these capabilities to life.
Thank you.
- Yeah.
Hello, everyone.
Today we're gonna be going
through this demo which showcases
a lot of the capabilities
that Amit was talking about.
Let's imagine that we are some kind
of clinical healthcare
provider, maybe a clinic
or possibly an emergency room.
And we want to accelerate
the amount of people
that we can see and we wanna
do this using machine learning,
artificial intelligence.
So what we're gonna do
is increase the amount
of patients we can see by
developing some kind of agent,
using a lot of the techniques
that Amit had mentioned.
We're gonna start by
hosting a language model
onto a SageMaker managed endpoint.
We're gonna fine tune it
and we're gonna orchestrate
that entire process using
SageMaker Pipelines.
We're gonna make some
friends along the way.
We're gonna incorporate MLflow
for observability and tracing
and then we're going to deploy that model
onto not just the managed endpoint,
but we're gonna log it
inside a model registry.
We'll look at SageMaker's
Model Registry as well
as MLflow's model registry
and how we can incorporate governance,
governance considerations like
a model card in both of them.
Then once our model is,
once our endpoint is hosted
and up and running,
we'll examine how we can
connect that endpoint
to something like an agent.
We'll start with an agent
that's built off Strands SDK.
If anyone's ever never
worked with Strands SDK,
it's a very lightweight capability,
a lightweight open source tool
that lets you build agents very quickly.
We'll also examine how you use Native MCP
and connect all of this with some
of the capabilities
within Bedrock AgentCore.
Another thing we're gonna do
that's a little interesting
is take advantage
of SageMaker's "bring your
own container" paradigm.
We're gonna use a new,
a new repository called
ml-container-creator.
The QR code links to that
if you wanted to take a look at it.
It's a very, very new,
just launched like two weeks
ago, open source repository.
So if any of you are
interested in contributing
to the open source world,
this is a great place to get
started because it is very new.
So without further ado, let's
take a look at this first part
of launching our model.
This is the part of the architecture
that we're gonna be focusing on
in this first part of the demo,
where we're going to be
training a Llama-3.2-3B
instruct model using QLora adaptation.
And we're gonna host it
on a SageMaker endpoint
using SGLang for serving.
So the SGLang container that
we're using is actually one
that we're bringing ourselves.
We're building it ourselves using some
of the assets generated
by the ml-container-creator repository.
So let's dive into how
this actually works.
The first part of any notebook
is a big list of imports.
Don't really bother yourself
with too many of these except
for these steps.
These are the pipeline definition files
that we're importing from our file system
that tell us how to execute
each part of the pipeline.
And we'll see in a moment
how they come together
to form a direct to day cyclic graph.
Kind of like what Amit had
shown on the slides before.
Each one of these has
special instructions about
how each step is supposed to
run, the inputs of one step,
get processed and become
the inputs to the next step
or the outputs of the first step become
inputs to the next step.
And I'll take a look, I'll
show you what one of these,
each one of these or one
of these steps looks like
in a moment.
As we continue, we're basically setting up
the rest of our environments
so that you know, we have
a couple of Boto3 clients
that we can work with a
fancy, you know, timer
for keeping track of things.
Where this really gets help interesting is
where we initialize our MLflow
environment for this demo.
We need to give our code a direction
or place to point all of
its telemetry requests,
all of its parameters and
metrics that we want to log
through each of these pipeline steps.
So what we're actually doing here is
we're capturing the MLflow ARN,
this is using a server
bound MLflow instance.
But now with serverless,
you can do the same thing.
And we're setting the tracking URI
and experiment name in our environment.
And this is this, these two lines of code,
you'll see them in the steps.
They're included here for completeness,
but they're actually used in the steps
where we're publishing metrics and logs
and configuration items
to MLflow within each pipeline step.
So this is where we set these up
and you'll see it more
in each step as they,
as we look through those.
Then we continue to identify
where we're getting our configuration
or container assets from.
I took the liberty of
using ml-container-creator
to generate an SGLang container
and then I uploaded those files to S3.
It's really just a Docker
file, a couple of serving file.
A serving file basically
spins up an SGLang server
onto whatever instance you deploy it on.
So I put all of those onto S3 already
and we are going to define
where we're creating that
inside Elastic Container Registry
'cause we're creating our own container
and deploying it onto
a SageMaker endpoint.
And we're gonna be using
Llama-3.2-3B instruct
for this fine tuning job.
So this is the model_id.
We're gonna get it directly
off of Hugging Face
inside our fine tuning job.
This was my Hugging Face key
and this wall of text is
the pipeline definition.
So each one of these blocks
is effectively a method call,
method call to the files
that we imported at the very beginning.
I'm not gonna spend too much time on this
'cause if you haven't worked
with Pipelines before,
you're not really going to appreciate
this big wall of text
like you would appreciate this diagram.
This is the directed acyclic graph
that is generated by the big
wall of text that we just saw.
And effectively it's starting
with building our container,
pre-processing a data set for fine tuning.
That data set is the freedom
intelligence data set,
FreedomIntelligence/medical-o1-reasoning-SFT
data
set.
It's effectively a series
of questions and answers
using chain of thought reasoning
that we're gonna use
to fine tune our model
to become a better clinical advisor.
So we're gonna pre-process that
to work for our Llama model.
We're gonna do QLora adaptation on it
and then we're gonna deploy it using our
custom SGLang container.
We're also gonna register this
inside SageMaker Model Registry
and the MLflow model registry.
So all of this stuff
that you, all of this,
these steps are represented
and defined in these method calls.
We stitch them together using
a SageMaker pipeline object
and you can see the steps
that we've imported earlier on
and we upsert the existing role.
Now this role has permission to do
all of the things we need it to do
within each part of the pipeline,
and the magic happens.
We run pipeline.start.
This initializes a pipeline run.
This creates the pipeline.
If it hasn't been created
for the first time,
I'm sorry, that's already been created,
this init executes a new pipeline run
and once it's successful,
'cause it eventually will be successful,
each of these steps will
show a green tick mark
and then you can kind of
double click onto each of these
and take a look at what has happened.
It'll point you to the CloudWatch logs,
other parameters for each pipeline step,
and this is how it looks within SageMaker.
We can go into the console now
and take a look at all of my failed runs
and my one successful run.
Or we can look at how
this looks in MLflow.
MLflow has a very similar layout.
Instead of the graph, we have
this list of pipeline steps
that have run under a run_id
and you can see the BYOC container data,
pre-processing QLora adaptation,
SGLang server model registration.
All of the same steps are
also logged in MLflow.
So let's look at one of these steps
to see how this was set up.
I'm gonna pull out the QLora fine tuning
orchestration step.
Each of these steps is about the same.
The only difference is
what's actually happening,
what you're actually instructing
the training job to do.
In this step, we're
instructing the training job
to fine tune the model,
but every training step is gonna have,
or every pipeline step is gonna have
some of the same elements.
We're gonna have an @Step annotation.
This allows us to define a step
separately from our notebook
or from our pipeline context
so that you don't have lots
and lots of very long methods
in the same file.
You can import them the
way we should before
as long as you define
a set of requirements
because what you're doing is
you're creating a training job
and you're executing this code inside
that SageMaker training job.
We're also passing information
about the MLflow tracking server.
This allows this step to publish metrics
and telemetry data back to MLflow.
Then some of the things
you'd come to expect
from a fine tuning job, training data set,
test data set, the model_id
that we're actually training.
In this scenario, I'm
using my Hugging Face,
we're pulling this
straight from Hugging Face.
So we have a Hugging Face
token that we're passing
and a role.
Here again, we see we're
setting the tracking_uri
and the experiment_name
just like we showed before
in the previous notebook.
This is how the execution
context knows how
to publish metrics and log data to MLflow.
Then we define the MLflow context.
We're also setting up automatic
system metrics logging.
This captures system metrics
like memory used, disk used,
networking network bytes I/O
and we're setting up the MLflow context
and we begin running the job.
And this is all the kinds of,
this is where we would set up
our training configuration.
And you can see eventually
as we get down to the end,
we're going to kick off a training job.
We're defining our compute input_data
and eventually a model trainer
before we actually call train.
Now all of the things that
are happening before that
are logs, pieces of
information being built
sent out to MLflow
to make it easier to understand
what has happened in this run.
We can take a look at
some of the system metrics
for the fine tuning job.
We can take a look at some of the metrics
that are published and tagged.
So these are the kinds of things
that you'll see when
you're writing these steps
for your SageMaker pipeline.
This is where it's gonna end up.
So now that we've defined our pipeline,
let's actually tell,
oh, I forgot to mention,
this is the model card
that was set up in the
model registration step.
This is an important piece to make note of
because this is a medical scenario
where an AI agent is advising
healthcare professionals.
And so model card should have
something similar to this
in, not exactly this,
but similar to this
when you're implementing
appropriate governance standards.
So we'll test the endpoint.
I have set up this endpoint a while ago,
that's why I'm hard
coding the endpoint name
and inference component.
And then we just create a
standard predictor like you would
with the SageMaker SDK,
and we will run a basic
prompt against this endpoint.
You're gonna see this prompt a lot,
45-year-old male with fever and cough,
temperature's 101.3
and heart rate is 98.
Give me a treatment
recommendation and a report.
Upload the report to S3 when done.
Now this is just a simple
model that's deployed on to,
an SGLang endpoint, doesn't
have tools capabilities,
it's just been fine tuned.
So we know that the model
should have the ability
to perform some basic medical reasoning
because of the fine tuning job,
but it's not enabled with tools to upload
or report to S3 yet.
So this is the output here.
You can see that the patient details
have been set up in a
nice report style format,
some kind of basic markdown syntax.
And the model did a fairly good job.
It's doing a, performing
a preliminary assessment
of the patient's symptoms to
show to suggest that it ha
that the patient is exhibiting signs
of pneumonia or something similar.
So this is the first part of our pipeline.
The model is deployed onto an endpoint.
It's using the BYOC container for SGLang
that we built ourselves.
We fine tuned it
and we have tracked our
entire experiment with MLflow
and we can go back and
take another look at it
if we want to.
Our model card is registered and logged
and I will show you the
model registry as well
within Mlflow
that shows you more
information about the model
and where it lives.
Version one.
So if you have, if you do this again
and you publish a new
version of that model,
it'll be added to the version list,
the model card might
get updated, et cetera.
So this is the first
part of our demo, right?
We've successfully
deployed a fine tuned agent
or a fine tuned model to SageMaker.
Let's give it some more capabilities.
Let's build out an agent,
an agent that can do some of the act,
take some of the actions
that we were talking
about like uploading to,
uploading the initial
diagnostic report to S3
for a clinician to review at a later time.
We might also want to give it
some additional capabilities
around patient lookups.
If a patient's already been there before,
how does the model understand?
How does the agent know
who this patient is?
Maybe there's a patient
database that we can query
to get more information
about that patient.
And so really what we're building out is
this piece down here.
We're gonna be using Bedrock AgentCore
to deploy a Strands agent
onto the AgentCore Runtime.
The Strands agent is something
we're gonna be building out
inside this notebook.
It's gonna be a pretty
large block of code.
I'm gonna walk you guys
through what that looks like.
And then we're gonna
use AgentCore Telemetry
to capture telemetry
data about each request
that the agent is handling.
So AgentCore Telemetry kind
of complimenting Mlflow
for observability.
Again, we have this big
long list of imports,
nothing really to pay too
much attention to here.
Same kind of environment set up.
And what I've done is I've
copied the endpoint listing
inside SageMaker.
This is the endpoint that's been deployed.
The name and the inference
component that we're working on,
I forgot to mention this model
is deployed on an inference
component so it scales
independent of the infrastructure
so long as there is capacity on
that infrastructure to scale.
So we define the endpoint name
and the inference component.
I hard code them for
the sake of this demo.
And now we're going to
build out the Strand agent.
The Strand agent is an f-string in Python.
So we're basically injecting variables
inside this f-string so
that it's instead of kind
of flipping between different files,
just easier to, for demo purposes.
So you can see we're
passing in the region,
the endpoint name an
S3 bucket for artifacts
and the inference component
is in here as well.
We've defined a patient dataclass,
basically some data information
about who the patient is,
what kind of symptoms they have.
You can imagine that
this might be analogous
to a record in a patient database.
I'm not a healthcare
professional so I have no idea
what you might find in a patient database,
but I took a stab at
what it might look like,
and this is what we came up with.
And I'm gonna skip to
the more interesting part
where we are...
Here we go.
We are invoking the SageMaker endpoint
that we defined earlier.
This is written inside of a method
called invoke_sagemaker_endpoint_async.
This method invokes the SageMaker endpoint
that we deployed earlier,
but there's a couple of other things
that are happening here.
First, we're defining our prompt.
And the prompt is
basically that same query
that I showed you guys earlier.
It's the same one we're gonna be using.
I'm not changing the the prompt,
it's a man with a,
a 47-year-old man with a
temperature exhibiting a cough.
What we're doing is wrapping this up in a,
in like in inside a,
a super prompt,
which basically says
that this is a clinical training scenario.
What would you do in this situation
as a clinical healthcare provider?
Once we have that in place,
we're gonna define our tracer.
Now tracers are
how AgentCore observability
captures trace data
and trace information inside your runtime.
So we've hard coded some attributes here
like the SageMaker endpoint
and inference component that
is servicing the request.
This might be really
helpful if you have an agent
that's making multiple
calls to several endpoints.
You don't know exactly
which one was called when.
This is a great piece of
information to keep inside a trace
as well as some of the hyper
parameters like max tokens,
the temperature and what
the actual prompt was.
These are examples of what
you might want to put in a,
inside an agent trace.
Then we define our payload.
We're using the Messages API.
So we have a system,
we have a component which
is the system prompt,
and we have a component
which is the user prompt,
again, that wrapped up
prompt of the gentleman
with symptoms of pneumonia.
And then we invoke our endpoint.
Now Strands allows us to do this
because we've defined an endpoint.
This is how Strands allows
us to define an endpoint
that we're going to use within our agent.
And once we are done
getting our response back from the model,
we set additional information
on our span object.
This is the context that
captures the trace.
We're going to set
information like the duration
of the model's response,
the length of the response
and additional metadata
about the success of the query.
So now we're gonna configure
this actual agent, right?
All we did was define a way
to query the SageMaker
endpoint which we deployed.
Let's configure the actual
agent using Strands.
Now I've set this up to
run inside the local mode
and inside a AgentCore Runtime context.
Agent core runtime uses FastAPI.
So you'll see that
there's a little bit of
overlap in this f-string
so that we can kind of illustrate
how to run this locally
and how to run this on AgentCore Runtime.
Here we're defining a SageMaker AI model.
This is the class that Strands SDK uses
to define an agent
or an LLM hosted on a SageMaker endpoint.
This was introduced
into Strands in August,
I believe it was.
So it's a fairly new capability
and it allows you to use
language models outside of
API based providers
such as Amazon Bedrock.
And then we just pass over
our prompt back to the model
in much the same way
that we just illustrated.
You can see we have
additional tracer information,
additional examples of how to use traces,
identifying some attributes on this trace,
and then defining a span
context within which
we are performing additional executions.
Now if we're not in local mode,
we're gonna create the
Bedrock AgentCore app.
This is effectively
creating a FastAPI server
and we're gonna call the
create_medical_agent.
That's that block of code that
creates the SageMaker model
or SageMaker AI model
object, the Strands agent.
And then we define our entry point,
which is again going to perform
effectively the same task
of passing a prompt over to the model.
Except this code will only
ever run when we deploy this
onto Bedrock AgentCore.
When we run this locally, which
I'll show you in a moment,
it's not gonna execute this block,
it's gonna execute
effectively the same logic,
just run in a local context.
Whoa, zoom out.
Okay.
So what I do here
eventually is write this,
write this big giant
f-string to a Python file
and now I'm going to actually run this.
We're gonna run this using
Shell Magic to run the Python,
run the Python code using the local flag.
And we're passing in
the same friendly prompt
that we've come to know and love.
And when we run this,
we're spinning up the file
inside our Python runtime
and it's passing out the message back
to the language model endpoint.
This is exactly what the agent is gonna do
once it's deployed to AgentCore Runtime.
We're just not, we're just
not accessing this agent code
over the runtime API yet.
So what it comes back with
is basically the same thing we saw earlier
based on the clinical scenario provided,
a 45-year-old male presents
with fever and cough,
his temperature is 101.3,
suggests some kind of
respiratory infection,
et cetera, et cetera.
So this is all running locally.
Now we deploy it.
Everything checks out so far.
Let's use this on the
Bedrock AgentCore Runtime.
So we're gonna use something
called the Bedrock AgentCore
Starter Toolkit.
If you've never seen this before,
it's a pretty fancy wrapper
around some of the
AWS CLI commands or API
commands you might need
to run, to deploy an AgentCore,
to deploy an agent to
the AgentCore Runtime
for the first time.
Effectively you're
defining a runtime object,
configuring your agent
and basically wrapping up the
Python code we wrote alongside
some requirements files and
other runtime information.
And then all we do
after we've defined this runtime object
is we execute the launch command.
Now I'm using launch with CodeBuild.
What this means is that
CodeBuild is gonna receive
the objects that we've built out
and it's gonna execute a
new CodeBuild execution
that effectively takes
all of the information
that we've built and walk through just now
and builds it out and deploys it onto
the Runtime control plane.
The AgentCore Runtime Control Plane.
Now I'm not gonna actually do this
'cause it takes a little bit to run,
but you can see what it looks like.
It's walking you through all of the steps
that CodeBuild takes to
actually build this agent.
Eventually we'll get an ARN at the end
and that ARN lets us run
or invoke the agent
using the AgentCore Runtime.
So I'm gonna invoke this
and when you deploy this inside AgentCore,
you're gonna see something like this.
The Strands medical agent, no
tools when it was deployed,
all the different
versions that are up there
as well as the active endpoint.
The active endpoint is what's
capturing the telemetry data
from our trace objects.
The active endpoint is
what's actually accruing logs
and the active endpoint is what
we're actually making calls to
when we invoke the AgentCore
Runtime with our prompts.
So we're gonna get probably
the same exact response
or very similar to the same
response that we showed earlier.
While we're waiting for that to finish,
you can see an example
of what some of the
telemetry data looks like
that we've captured inside our agent.
So this is a screenshot of
the observability window
inside CloudWatch.
When you select the
observability dashboard
inside of your agent's
view inside AgentCore,
it's gonna take you to CloudWatch
and you'll see something a lot like this,
the different sessions and
traces that have happened
within the agent's lifetime.
Different layers of invocation.
For example, the post request
to the SageMaker endpoint,
which is like the final
layer of that invocation.
It's superseded by an API
call to the SageMaker API
and then it's wrapped
up in some other layers.
And so we can kind of pull
this apart at different layers
to see what's happening At
each layer of the invocation.
We can also see the amount of load
or the amount of resources
consumed by the agents.
So how many virtual CPU
hours it's consumed,
how much memory it's consumed
in gigabyte hours, et cetera.
And wow, this is still going.
There we go.
Well, it wouldn't be a demo...
(Dan laughs)
We'll come back to that.
If I were a braver man, I'd
run the same thing with Bodo3.
At one point, this worked.
So take a look at the output
and this is an example of what
the trace might look like.
This is a trace with an error,
not a timeout, unfortunately.
This is an error that shows us
we have malformed JSON.
Some of the JSON keys or maybe values
don't have the right number
of quotes around them.
So it's gonna throw an error.
We fixed that and now the
entire chain runs nicely.
So this is a great example
of how you can use tracing
to improve your,
to kind of identify issues
deep within your execution.
Now we have a few more minutes left.
We haven't actually
built out any tools yet,
so I'm gonna go through
the tools part of this
and I'm gonna switch
gears away from Strands
into Native MCP.
And the reason I wanna do this is
to showcase the capabilities
of AgentCore Gateway at the very end.
Effectively what we're doing here
is building out another agent
in almost exactly the same
way that we did before.
But instead of using Strands
and the SageMaker AI model object,
we're building a custom MCP server,
as well as an MCP client
that will make calls to the server
which has methods coded
into handle requests
to the tools list and tools call endpoints
as part of the MCP protocol.
So again, we have much the same
initialization logic at the
beginning of our notebook.
We're gonna be creating
a Bedrock AgentCore role.
This is a pretty standard policy document
for a lambda function
that's gonna be making calls
to the Bedrock AgentCore Control Plane.
And then we'll define our MCP server.
Now this is where I wanna
spend a little time,
and we only have five minutes left,
so I'm gonna spend some
time walking through
how we're implementing these
two methods, tools/list
and tools/call.
Tools/list prints out the list of tools
that our MCP server knows
how to execute, right?
Patient_search and save_medical_report.
Patient_search is taking
in some general identifier,
probably a compound key for
a patient_search database.
In this scenario it's just
generically identifier
and it doesn't matter
'cause I've hard coded
to return one patient for demo purposes,
and then save_medical_report,
which takes in the content that
we're trying to upload to S3
where we're uploading it to
and what kind of format.
Perhaps we wanna support more formats
besides just markdown.
You can imagine a world
where we're supporting
lots of different patient portals.
So we might wanna support
different kinds of file formats.
Now we implementing, that was tools/list.
Tools/call is taking in requests
from the lambda function
and identifying which tool
we're actually calling,
grabbing the parameters
that are passed into that,
into that request
and forwarding them on
to the method itself.
So in the scenario where we're calling
the save_medical_report tool,
we're extracting the arguments
and passing them to the
save_medical_report method.
And the same for patient search.
These methods are implemented down here.
You can see patient_search
is just returning John Doe
with a couple of, you know,
basic medical history.
And save_medical_report is basically
dropping the response
from the language model
into a markdown object.
Here it is, whatever that content is,
it's getting dropped into a markdown file
and uploaded to S3.
Fairly basic capability,
fairly basic MCP tool call that would,
our model is now where our
agent will now be equipped
to perform for us.
So this has already been
deployed to AWS Lambda
and we can now make calls to this.
You can see it's all the same
code that we wrote before.
We deploy the, this is the code block
that deploys the Lambda function
and then we recreate an agent.
So the agent we're recreating here
is effectively the same
agent that we had before.
He uses that f-string notation
to make it a little easier
to read inside of a notebook,
but we're doing the same kind
of idea as what we did before.
Now what makes this,
when we're adding the ability
for tools to be called here is...
It's just searching through
because it's a little
hard to find everything.
We're applying a little bit
of determinism to our agent,
telling it which tools
to call in what order.
We're telling it which
patients have come in,
the agent is receiving the initial prompt
from whatever interface
that we've built out
and it's calling the mcp_gateway
to get the patient information,
perform some analysis on
that patient information
and generate a report out of that.
So all of this is,
I'm running out of time so I apologize,
I'm gonna skip to the actual
report that's generated.
And this is the markdown report
that's generated from this.
Can see the same information
that's printed out
inside our notebook is
now printed out here.
I downloaded this directly from S3
so it's not something that
I saved in my file system,
trust me.
It's definitely downloaded from S3.
And now we've enabled our model
to make tool calls within AgentCore,
within the AgentCore Runtime.
Now if we wanted to, we
can actually extend this
to not use native MCP
but to actually build a gateway.
We can actually build a
gateway using AgentCore.
So I've already taken
the liberty of doing that
and registered this lambda function
as an MCP target on the gateway.
If we go down to the bottom,
we're using the Request API
to make calls to the
gateway like list_tools()
and call_tool.
We're defining our gateway URL here
and using requests, we can
actually make calls to that.
And this is what the output looks like.
This is the JSON that
comes back from the gateway
using the MCP protocol.
These are the tools that are supported,
the patient_search and
generate_medical_report.
And this is the output
of calling those tools.
Patient search returns PATIENT-12345
named John Doe, et cetera.
And this is the structured
report located at this location
in S3.
So I apologize, I went
a little bit over time.
I'm going to pass it
over to Ying from SGLang
to take us home.
- Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for Amit and Dan
for the great introduction
about SageMaker ai.
I'd also like to give you some insights
about the underlying SGLang
so that you have a better idea of how
to use leverages advantage.
We, the SGLang, has been,
is a community building
open source project.
So the development momentum is continuous.
And I'd like to talk a
little bit about the,
the last quarter roadmap
of SGLang development.
And there are two focuses here.
First is we have spent
a lot of effort recently
on improving user experiences
and also we collaborating
with all the open source model
providers so that we aim
to run our latest open models efficiently
at large scale from day zero.
And second, we spend a lot recent focus
on big refactoring.
So to make all advanced features
compatible with each other
to achieving high
performance and usability.
So there are a list of
five major components here,
PD disaggregation
that we are keep improving the
compatibility now we adding
more features that was
supported in non-PD scenarios,
now also in PD scenarios
And speculative decoding,
we are implementing the
V2 version so that it's a,
with a better engineering design
to accommodate different algorithms,
speculative algorithms and
all kinds of parallelism.
We are doing Refactor on
PP for pipeline parallelism
and EP for export parallelism.
So that reduce the bubble
and make it more efficient.
For all kinds of memory pool,
the refactor work on the
memory pool V2 will support
different attention mechanisms,
especially optimized for
the hybrid attention,
including veneer attention,
window attention, full attention.
And overlap scheduler is
a unique feature in SGLang
that we carefully designed
the schedule logic
so that we overlap the CPU overhead
under GPU computation.
So achieve zero overhead in CPU
and then we are now working on making
all those five components to
be compatible with each other.
And this here emphasized on how
we focus on refactoring
because real engineering is
at the core of our philosophy.
Also like to give you some
highlight on other features,
one of them is hierarchical KV Cache.
This feature is, it will be useful,
very useful for agentic
application that have many turns
and huge cache reuse opportunities.
Amit also mentioned
that in previous slides.
SGLang for this feature,
we utilize multiple layers
of the storage to store the KV Cache,
including the GPU memory, CPU memory
and also the remote memory
that utilizing NVME.
We support multiple
backends, the DeepSeek 3FS,
Mooncake and NVIDIA NIXL.
And this is one experimental
result on a certain workload
that we can see it achieves
a better, much better latency
and also much higher throughput
because within this feature
we achieve much higher cache hit rate.
Another highlight,
Speculative Decoding V2,
Amit also mentioned before
that this Speculative Decoding
is a very powerful optimization,
especially for online serving
when you have a very small batch size.
It can give you usually two
to three times speed up.
And especially when we came
into the reasoning model,
the reasoning model usually
have tons of multiple tokens
and Speculative Decoding is, will be the,
a great way,
a very good way to
accelerate in that case.
And in V2 design we add one more feature,
so we make it compatible
with the overlap schedule.
So previously the Speculative Decoding
was implemented in a way that we
iterate for one decoding step
and then SGLang's CPU scheduling
and then another decoding step.
And in this new version we have been able
to decouple further for the CPU,
for the CPU control plan
and GPU compute plan.
So now we,
hide the CPU scheduling part
under the GPU computation
and not only remain one mapping
that store the value in GPU
and only the pointers in CPU.
So we only maintain that map,
then after each iteration
we just have a small step
to store the future
tensor to map to this map
and then read the future
tensors from the map.
This help us reduce the
overhead by further 10 to 20%.
So when we came into the
large scale serving world,
that's also always the focus of SGLang,
and we have been deployed in
production serving scenarios
for really very large scale.
So prefilled decode desegregation
and Wide Expert Parallelism
are two core features that have been used,
especially for the DeepSeek use cases.
Separate prefill and
decode endings can help us
to achieve better specialization
for prefill phase and the decode phase.
And so also we can have
a better latency control
and those for the Expert Parallelism
use a large degree of the EP to,
we can increase the
concurrency and the throughput.
And then the result is, we,
in the first half of this year,
we have been the first
open source framework
to match the official DeepSeek results.
And this is a demo so that
we can have the deployment
for the prefill with a
different paralleism strategy
with one paralleism strategy
and the decode with a
different paralleism strategy
and within the KB transfer
engine in between.
So moving forward we also
have first optimize this large
scale deployment on new
hardware especially so
that we came into the, we
go into the next slide that,
we came into the new world
of the Rack-Scale
Blackwell GPU deployments.
And the future of inference,
will be at rack scale
such as the GB200 MVL72.
So previously like we
deployed model on one,
no, four GPUs, but now we
have the 72 GPUs in one rack,
they're connected by unlink.
So that enables us to do more optimization
for the large, really large scale PDNA,
especially the EP, Expert Parallelism.
SGLang optimizes it
then with prefill-decode
like the PD that we mentioned
and also the wide Expert Parallelism,
we think by utilizing the new features,
new kernels for Blackwell
and also the new
auto communication kernels.
And this is one result we
published in summer that shows
how much performance gain
we have for the GB200.
We're now also working on the GB300.
So that will be,
I think that I can just
summarize here for the,
those highlight features
and those, some of the features
are still in experimental status,
so they're not always
turned on by default.
So if you, I always
encourage you to go to our,
our documentation website
to see what's the most recent updates
and the guides
to turn on those optimizations.
Yeah, and the last thing is we recently,
also recent last month we released
the component in addition
to language model.
We now support image and video generation,
also image in, image out.
And this we call this SGLang Diffusion
that accelerates these,
this image video generation
by 1.2 times generally
and sometimes in special cases
could up to six times a bot.
In future models we think
will be multimodal-in,
multimodal-out that are combining
in auto regressive language
models and diffusion models.
And this, in this release we
have from this metric benchmark
that we compared with
the existing diffuser,
Hugging Face diffuser, you
can see the performance gain
and also we the, on the
right figure we list
how those different
optimization techniques can help
with the performance throughput.
And majorly there are two techniques.
One is a sequential sequence parallelism
and another one is CFG parallelism.
And when we combine them, combine the two,
we got even higher improvement,
even better improvement.
Yeah, I think that ends my part then.
- Okay, so we covered
a lot of ground today.
We, I'm just gonna do a
quick recap of the challenges
that we referred to in the very beginning.
Here we go.
Model customization can be
a time consuming process.
It can be a little expensive at times
and it may be unclear how
you optimize that workflow.
What we've discussed today is really meant
to give you a couple of tips and tricks
on how you might do that, right?
Taking into consideration...
I think the clicker stopped working.
There we go.
How we might leverage
fully managed training jobs
to allow you to continuously
repeat these experiments
over and over
and optimize that way
without having to manage all
of the experimentation harness.
We talked about how you might host
SageMaker models more effectively.
And Ying just went through
several great stats about
how SGLang is a really
great model serving engine
for efficient model serving and inference,
end to end observability
with managed MLflow
and now managed MLflow
serverless, which is a,
I think it's a little
more cost effective than
hosted MLflow.
And we talked about using
SageMaker Pipelines to be able
to repeat these experiments over and over
and over again so
that you can effectively
scale your experimentation.
Finally, tracking and auditing
and versioning models within
SageMaker Model Registry,
MLflow model registry,
giving you the ability
to determine exactly
where you're gonna focus
your optimization efforts.
So thank you all for attending.
This is a link to the demo video.
The code is not available yet on GitHub.
It will be at some point soon,
but this is a link to the demo video
and if you go into your
app, the AWS events app,
don't forget to leave a
review for the session so
that we know how to
improve it for next time.
Thank you very much.
(audience claps)